l' incendie du collège d'enseignement
secondaire dans le 19e arrondissement de
paris
on compte à cette heure ci 19 morts et
quatre disparus
les victimes sont des enfants qui
participaient à des cours de musique
donnés chaque mardi soir par le
conservatoire du 19e arrondissement dans
les locaux du cs un professeur et la
concierge font partie des victimes pour
le moment aucun indice ne permet de
donner les raisons de cet incendie de ce
drame
19h45 c'était hier soir le drame était
déjà jours
aujourd'hui voici ce qu'il reste du cs
de la rue edmond pailleron dans le 19e
arrondissement de construction récente
trois ans à peine ce collège fait de
poutrelles métalliques dalle de béton et
de cloisons de bois avait été édifié en
quelques mois sur une ancienne carrière
comment expliquer cet effondrement total
du bâtiment à la suite d'un incendie
aussi violent soit il quelles sont les
origines de l'incendié les victimes
ont-elles péri brûlés ou asphyxiés ou
écrasées autant de questions autant de
réponses auxquelles désespère tentons de
répondre
il était 19h45 hier soir lorsque le
sinistre s'est déclaré
trois classes de solfège et une classe
de piano se dérouler au deuxième étage
du collège les flammes qui ont éclaté
sans qu'il y est eu d'explosion
semble-t-il ont pris de l'extension à
une vitesse extraordinaire
et lorsque les pompiers sont arrivés sur
place très vite pourtant en moins de
quatre minutes
il n'y avait déjà plus rien à faire pour
éviter l'embrasement totale du bâtiment
deux heures plus tard l'édifice n'était
plus qu'un tas de décombres et seul un
mur restait encore de vous l'école
alerte est donnée
les professeurs font évacuer les enfants
mais dans la plus grande confusion ni
les élèves ni les professeurs ne
connaissait les lieux
c'était la première fois que les cours
du conservatoire était donné dans ce
collège
une épaisse fumée empêchent l'accès aux
escaliers de sortie
c'est donc par les fenêtres qu'il faut
fuir 22h15 l'incendié maîtrisé
on pense que le pire a été évité mais
c'est alors que la vérité
une quinzaine de victimes
ce sont des enfants
et eva donné l'état des corps la
situation à laquelle je voulais voir
moi-même qu'on peut croire qu'ils
étaient aux dernières et à cette photo
si des décombres de la partié congrès du
vote il s'est alors la consternation les
parents des élèves du conservatoire
alertée par radio attendaient des
nouvelles qu'étaient devenus leurs
enfants etait-il hospitalisé r est il
dans la rue affolé où était-il resté
prisonnier de l'amas de ferraille
la tragédie s'est installé le général
des pompiers l humain et fonde le
pensait initialement qu'il y avait une
victime puisqu'on nous avaient dit qu'un
enfant n'était pas sorti qu'à la plume
plus d'un je suis navré mais les
pompiers ont fait leurs devoirs tout
leur métier avec beaucoup de courage
derrière d'après les premiers témoins 19
morts dont seize adolescents et trois
adultes
tel est le bilan un bilan qui reste
provisoire car il reste peut-être des
victimes sous les décombres
michel chevalet on ne s'est encore
absolument rien des causes de cet
incendie
les ce que l'on peut se demander
maintenant si pourquoi cet incendie
s'est il propagée si rapidement
bien sûr il ya ce facteur là il ya aussi
la sempiternelle question que se posent
bon nombre de mères de famille ce soir
c'est le savoir aussi pourquoi les
superstructures se sont effondrés aussi
rapidement si vous voulez c'est la
réponse la plus facile à porter en effet
c'est établissement a été construit avec
une ossature métallique qui est
traditionnel en quelque sorte et sous
l'action de la chaleur les poutres
métalliques
si vous voulez s'allongent se dilate et
elle commence par repousser les murs
ensuite vers 400 degrés l'acier qui
constituent ces poutres et bien c'est
acier perd sa résistance mécanique les
poutres poids sous la charge et les
plafonds les plancher s'écroulent alors
reste le problème comme vous l'évoquez
de la rapidité de l'incendié alors là
les choses bien sûr sont beaucoup plus
complexes et de but en blanc on est
tenté de faire le procès du père
fabriquait c'est trop facile si j'ose
dire il faut d'abord voir que ce
établissement est construit la façon
suivante il est d'abord une chape de
béton une dalle de béton dessus une
ossature une charpente métallique
les murs extérieurs sont faits de dalles
de béton d'un mètre sur 1 0 mètre
soixante vont tous fait un combustible
enfin à l'intérieur et bien
l'aménagement traditionnels
établissements scolaires c'est à dire
des cloisons des planches est fait de
matériaux composites c'est à dire d'un
sandwich de deux plaques d'aggloméré de
plaques de bois avec à l'intérieur de la
mousse de polystyrène alors là me direz
vous bien ce c'est inflammable ces
combustibles
alors là c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
car dans le domaine de la tenue au feu
des matériaux il faut distinguer trois
choses trois critères qu'on mélange
souvent il ya tout d'abord ce qu'on
appelle la combustible it et du matériau
c'est à dire sa faculté son aptitude à
brûler le bois et combustibles bien sûr
le faire pour vous ne l'est pas en fait
ne l'est pas des conditions ordinaires
et pilia l'inflammabilité c'est ce que
vous voyez en ce moment sur votre écran
envoyé un voile de coton s'enflamme avec
une simple forme de brique est par
contre se voile en tergal refuse de
s'enflammer il est ininflammable et
pourtant c'est un matériau synthétique
autre critère c'est un test qui est
effectuée au laboratoire national
d'essais à paris c'est la tenue au feu
on soumet l'échantillon de
thériault à un four à 5 150 degrés et on
regarde comment s'enflamme le matériau
et on regarde aussi ce qui est
extrêmement important la vitesse de
propagation de la flamme conclusions
deux conclusions après ces tests tout
d'abord les matériaux nouveaux que l'on
met que l'on semblent incriminer danse
dans cet incendie est bien les matériaux
nouveaux ne sont pas plus inflammable
que les matériaux traditionnels mais
simplement la vitesse de propagation est
beaucoup plus importante que dans les
matériaux traditionnels en raison d' en
légèreté
deuxièmement quelle est la validité de
cet essai là toute la question
les tests de validité de résistance au
feu ne sont obtenus qu'à partir d'un
échantillon comme vous l'avez vue qui
est extrêmement réduit qui fait environ
un demi mètre carré alors d'un demi
mètre carré à une cloison entière qui
fait plusieurs mètres carrés il y a
comme disent les spécialistes il ya un
fossé à franchir alors une boutade
peut-être mais je crois qu'elle pose
bien le problème si vous voulez pour
édicter des normes de sécurité eh bien
il faudrait dire qu'il faudrait
construire un établissement est
malheureusement y mettre le feu pour
voir comment il se comporte
l'enquète sur le drame du crs du 19e
arrondissement pourrait bien mettre en
cause les matières employées pour la
construction de l'établissement
il ya d'abord les témoignages d'une
anime sur l'extrême rapidité avec
laquelle le feu s'est propagé
il n'y a rien d'officiel mais les
enquêteurs auraient noté la mauvaise
qualité des cloisons fait de blocs
d'agglo mad aggloméré séparé selon
certains commentaires par des plaques de
matières plastiques bien sûr cela n'a
rien à voir avec l'origine de l'incendié
mais les matériaux utilisés devraient
pouvoir supporter les flammes pendant un
temps minimum nous avons pu poser ce
matin quelques questions au président
directeur général de la société qui
construit les crs de ce type
monsieur le fait vous êtes pdg de la
société qui avait choisi les matériaux
qui ont servi à la construction du cs
edouard payant un reproche est fait
enfin des accusations sont faites on
prétend qu'il y à du plastique dans ses
cloisons
qu'en est il exactement et bien c'est
exact que c'est notre société qui
choisit les matériaux qu'ils doivent
être utilisés dans ce système et qui les
soumet ensuite à l'agrément du ministère
de la construction
je démens formellement qu'il y ait la
moindre parcelle de plastique dans ses
cloisons ses cloisons sont constitués
par des panneaux de fibres de bois
aggloméré de 35 mm de 50 mm d'épaisseur
ces panneaux sont accouplés deux par
deux pour former une cloison 264 mm
d'épaisseur
à l'intérieur il y à un vide est
absolument aucun plastique la résistance
au feu contrôlé par le laboratoire est
de 1h ou 1h30 ou même deux heures
suivant l'épaisseur de chacune des
contrepoison l'a1 l'enduit effet au four
cet enduit est absolument un combustible
ces matériaux sont agréés par le centre
scientifique et technique du bâtiment
comme difficilement inflammable
après avoir été testé ces matériaux sont
commandés chez certains fournisseurs par
nos soins nous nous assurerons sur le
chantier que ces mêmes matériaux sont
livrés par les fournisseurs conforme à
notre demande du reste enquêtes en cours
fait des prélèvements qui démontreront
absolument le bien fondé de ces
affirmations
monsieur lesage jour merci à vous
cognacq jay o le voyait selon les
accusations dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure la polémique n'est pas terminé
il faudra surtout expliquer bien sûr la
rapidité d'extension du feu surtout si
les matériaux ne sont pas en cause comme
on vient de nous le dire
je vous rappelle que l' incendie a fait
le corps d'un professeur n'a d'ailleurs
pas encore été retrouvé ce matin les
parents des victimes devaient se réunir
pour examiner la possibilité de créer
une association afin de faire valoir le
droit des familles il ya aussi en marge
de ce drame des incendies criminels qui
s'était déclaré jeudi dans deux collèges
d'enseignement secondaire de la région
parisienne on peut pour l'instant que
les attribuer à des déséquilibrés ou à
des personnes qui voudraient faire
croire à la thèse de l'attentât pour le
cs du 19e arrondissement
sont des jeunes élèves du ce1 s de la
rue edouard pailleron qui ont allumé un
incendie dans lequel sont mortes
vingt-et-une personnes dont 17 de leurs
camarades ils ont tout avoué aux
policiers la nuit dernière le principal
responsable est un garçon de 15 ans qui
aurait agi par vengeance à la suite de
sanctions et six de ses camarades
étaient au courant de son projet de
relance us marquette précisément vous
avez à faire une fois le soir du 6
février quand la leyre tofu donné rue de
voir faille rond quelques minutes plus
tôt un jeune garçon avait répondu de
litres d'essence sur les corbeilles à
papier l'armoire et les chefs d'une
salle d'étude du rez-de-chaussée
l' incendie devait dire les témoins
s'est propagé à une vitesse foudroyante
à 20h40
tout le bâtiment en flammes s'est
effondré toutefois les sauveteurs
français encore il n'y avait aucune
victime
malgré la présence dans l'établissement
au moment de l' alerte d'une
cinquantaine de personnes il s'agissait
de jeunes enfants âgés de 8 à 13 ans
élève du conservatoire municipal de
musique venus un cours de solfège
accompagnés de leurs professeurs entre
18 heures et 19 heures 30 au ciné club
de l'école ont projeté le film alexandre
le bienheureux
après la séance le jeune pyromane
pénétra dans la salle d'étude du rez de
chaussée quelques heures auparavant
anne ses camarades avaient acheté 2
litres d'essence dans une droguerie du
quartier j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à
enflammer les sens que j'ai répondu
déclara le sénat sans dire à ses
camarades et complices ils l'attendaient
à l'extérieur
à ce moment là le groupe ignorait qu'une
soixantaine d'enfants de l'orage se
trouvaient à l'intérieur et vers 22
heures ce qui n'était jusque alors qu'un
violent incendie devint brusquement une
tragédie plus de deux heures après le
début du sinistre les sapeurs pompiers
en fouillant les décombres du cs
découvrait les corps des victimes
désaveu terrible la nuit dernière ce de
cette jeune garçon le plus âgé à 15 ans
le plus jeune à peine 14
les enquêteurs qui avaient dès le début
retenu l'hypothèse de l' incendie
criminel au même titre que les autres
hypothèses avaient commencé dès le
lendemain de la catastrophe par
interroger tous les élèves
qui avait fait l'objet de sanctions
durant ces derniers jours et qui aurait
été susceptible par conséquent de mettre
le feu au cs pour se venger
c'est au cours de ses auditions les
policiers ont été amenés à suspecter un
certain nombre de jeunes gens ceux là
même qui ont donc tout avoué la nuit
dernière un mois et demi après l
incendie dramatique du collège de la rue
edouard pailleron à paris un incendie
qui avait fait 20 morts
on a appris hier soir les résultats de
l'enquêté administrative
plusieurs anomalies dans la construction
du bâtiment ont été constatés elles
seront évidemment porté au dossier
sans préjuger des suites judiciaires qui
seront données à cette affaire les
poteaux porteurs en acier devait être
protégé par un enduit à base d'amiante
dans la partie non visible à hauteur d
au plafond il ne l'était pas dans le
vide des faux plafonds devait se trouver
un cloisonnement coupe feu il n'y en
avait pas la façade était doublée pour
une isolation thermique par des plaques
de polystyrène expansé c'est un produit
dangereux qui n'aurait pas dû se trouver
là ce sont les trois différences que l'
enquête administrative a décelé entre le
cahier des charges et le bâtiment
définitif mais attention on ne peut pas
affirmer à l'heure actuelle que ces
anomalies de construction ont joué un
rôle dans la propagation du feu c'est au
juge sablayrolles chargé de l'enquêté
judiciaire de le dire en attendant on
peut s'interroger
plusieurs faits dramatiques ces temps
derniers nous ont laissés en désarroi ce
désarroi caire à ce que le public n'est
plus habitué au feu dans un appartement
moderne on ne voit plus de feu alors que
nos anciens avaient l'habitude du feu il
le voyait tous les jours dans le poêle
et avant dans un cheminot et puis la
sagesse élite et ses anciens nous donner
le moyen de nous défendre contre des
incendies alors que nous avions peu de
moyens quand je dis les fargeaulais du
deal prévenir héros prévenir incendie au
moyen âge notamment en prenant soin de
revêtir de plâtre les maisons apport de
bois et c'était un homme une ordonnance
royale qui le pl sql et il y en a encore
une fois 2762 777 qui doit être de
cordell parce que maintenant on ne sait
plus se préserver
on sait lutter contre le feu mais il
faut dire que la construction moderne
utilise des matériaux qui contiennent un
potentiel calorifique tels que le
moindre incendie plan d annuler
logarithmique libère en très peu de
temps un énorme potentiel calorifique 1
atteignant des pics de température et
toutes les conséquences c'est à dire que
tout ce qui est tout ce qui vient de la
chimie organique il commence par
distiller l'air et appauvri en oxygène
il se produit de l'oxydé de carbone dont
la dose létale est très rapidement
atteintes epona des catastrophes et des
pertes humaines bien pour les feux de
demain on n'est pas tellement des années
parce que on a déjà de ces lieux
règlement de prévention mais il faut se
dire que nous aurons à parfaire ses
règlements et que c'est là une tâche
continue il faudra évidemment faire en
sorte qu' on puisse intervenir très vite
et quand julien dé revenir donner
d'abord la lèvre avant oclio feu et tout
le monde se sauver à leur double il faut
qu'on reprenne ce vieux réflexe
en fait ce qu'il faut c'est ne pas se
contenter des règlements qui existent il
faut ne pas y ne pas hésiter à refaire
sans cesse ses règlements ces règlements
ne sont pas immuables
ils ne sont pas figées il faut qu'ils
soient sans cesse sur le métier la
sécurité a toujours un pas de retard sur
les techniques de pointe et il faut que
ce pas ne se transforme pas en fossé
l'association des victimes du cs de la
rue pailleron à paris donnait une
conférence de presse cet après midi son
porte parole a été formel nous refusons
d'invoquer la fatalité at il dit il y à
de nombreuses fautes à différents
niveaux
les parents des victimes du cs s'étaient
réunis ce matin à l'occasion de la
conférence de presse que leurs
représentants ont tenu chez l'un d'entre
eux il s'agissait pour les porte parole
de l'association des parents des
victimes de faire part de leurs propres
conclusions
à la suite de l'analyse du rapport d'
enquête alors la première chose que nous
voudrions dire c'est que nous refusons
absolument que l'on évoque la fatalité
certains commentaires certaines
indications du rapport administratif
le routard de la leyre tu le fait que
les enfants ne connaissaient pas les
lieux l'extinction de l'électricité
semble être autant d'arguments qui
plaident rers la faveur d'une certaine
fatalité leur faisons absolument nous
refusant absolument cette direction nous
disons qu'il ya des fautes et que par
conséquent il y a des responsabilités
parmi les fautes sur lesquels vous avez
insisté parce qu'ayant ce matin eh bien
nous avons repris nous avons commenté le
rapport administratif qui fait
apparaître trois fautes importantes
qui sont d'une part la présence de
certains matériaux en particulier du
polystyrène expansé qui sont le fait que
les recoupements obligatoire tous les 25
mètres n'ont pas été respectées et que
l'autre par certains éléments de
structure était pas protégés contre le
feu à l'aide de revêtement d'amiante
pour madame simoni le fait de
reconnaître certaines erreurs n'explique
pas que l'éducation nationale ait pu
choisir un tel système de construction
au delà du drame de la rue edouard
pailleron il s'agit maintenant de savoir
comment à l'avenir
on évitera de telles catastrophes je
pense qu'il ya une chose très importante
a à dire ce qu'il y a énormément dont
une cinquantaine de bâtiments du même
type dans lesquels dont les enfants
fréquentent quotidiennement et dans la
mesure où ce système n'est pas un défaut
d'un cas particulier mais du système
lui-même il est essentiel d'en démontrer
la faille et je crois que c'est le
devoir de nous parents et aussi
l'éducation nationale le contrôle et les
plans au niveau des plans reprendre tout
le dossier de façon à ce que s'il ya une
faille des normes qui soit passé qu'elle
soit vraiment contrôler sérieusement
[Musique]
c'était le 6 février 1973 à paris des
enfants suivaient un cours de musique
dans une salle de collège d'enseignement
secondaire rue edouard pailleron
il était à peu près 7 heures 20h20 20h30
le feu se déclarait dans une salle de
classe se propager rapidement 20
victimes
c'était un enfant qui inconsciemment
avait mis le feu aux 6es
mais ce collège avait été bâtie selon
des procédés de construction nouveau
léger rapide
on apprend aujourd'hui l'inculpation du
plus haut responsable de cette
construction de ce genre de construction
un haut fonctionnaire monsieur jean reno
actuellement conseiller à la cour des
comptes hier directeur des équipements
scolaires et universitaires le collège
d'enseignement secondaire de la rue
edouard pailleron dans le 19e
arrondissement avait été ouvert à la
rentrée d'octobre 1970 c'était un
bâtiment moderne de quatre étages qui
accueillait 900 élèves 55 100es de ce
type ont été construits en france c'est
monsieur jean reno alors directeur de
l'équipement scolaire universitaire et
sportif au ministère de l'éducation
nationale qui avait présidé aux choix du
procédé de construction modulaire et
conclut le marché portant sur les
établissements du type clape ce brevet
de la société métallurgique anglaise
brockhouse je construis un seul ace par
jour avait dit monsieur foucher en
défendant son budget de l'éducation
nationale devant les députés en 5 en
effet de 1965 à 70 près d'un million de
places ont été construites
il s'agissait à l'époque de faire vite
face à l'accroissement des effectifs
scolaires le 6 février 73 à 19h45 c'est
le drame un garçon de 14 ans qui se sent
mal aimé par ses professeurs achète 2
litres d'essence légère du white spirit
et avec la complicité de cinq autres
élèves
mais le faire établissements en quelques
minutes tout s'embrase
on retire des décombres d'un corps j'ai
été bouleversée je suis j'vous le dis
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
d'abord d' temps de en tant que père de
famille bien sûr en tant que
fonctionnaire du ministère d'éducation
et à ce dernier titre je n'ai pas
conscience et je sais que je ne suis pas
responsable du drame qui a été
déclenchée par cet incendie
je crois que c'est vous monsieur le
conseiller qui aviez choisi ce type de
construction j'étais à l'époque
responsable au ministère de l'éducation
nationale je ne peux pas vous dire pour
répondre d'une manière précise à la
question que vous posez parce que les
procédures sont complexes que les choses
sont sont difficiles ne sont pas simples
mais comprenait aussi et je vous prie de
m'en excuser que je ne peux pas
aujourd'hui ici et à cette heure
dans ces circonstances vous en dire plus
car ce serait anticipée sur ce que je
dois au magistrat instructeur
on a bâti en croyant au miracle diront
les experts commis au lendemain de la
catastrophe par le juge sablayrolles
pour étudier le dossier technique du crs
malgré les inculpations déjà prononcé
contre 6 personnes l'association des
victimes avaient l'impression avant
l'inculpation de monsieur raynaud qu'une
certaine lenteur judiciaire s'opposait à
la découverte des véritables
responsabilités
cette inculpation c'est l'aboutissement
de
deux années de recherche des
investigations que nous avons poursuivi
pour comprendre ce qui avait pu se
passer le 6 février 1973 donc deux
années pendant lesquelles nous avons
appris beaucoup
on comprit beaucoup quant à la politique
de construction à la manière sur la
manière dont était construit un certain
nombre d'établissements scolaires ici
dans ce pays et nous avons constaté que
plus de 80 établissements étaient des
frère jumeau de celui ci et que près de
2000 établissements en toute la france
étaient construits suivant des procédés
industrialisés léger d'ailleurs un
certain nombre d' incendies ont eu lieu
après pailleron souvenez-vous à nice
ensuite à sarcelles et ensuite à
canteleu qui tous ont ravagé totalement
les bâtiments avec une rapidité tout à
fait effrayant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]